قتلت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مواطنين
فلسطينيين خلال اقتحامها فجر الاحد مخيمين
في الضفه الغربيه كما اصابت فلسطينيين في
وقت لاحق بقصف شرقيه قطاع غزه تزامن هذا
مع اقتحام مئات المتشددين اليهود المسجد
الاقصى وتحذير رئاسه الفلسطينيه من
استمرار تصعيد الاحتلال الذي اعتبرته
الرئاسه وحركه حماس ترجمه لخطاب نتنياهو
في الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اذا كان ذكاء خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
مره سائل التي يريد الاحتلال توجيهها
بمواصله تصعيده في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
وتعزيز قوات قرب غزه بعد لقاء بايدن
نتنياهو
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان نقرا ربط السلطه
الفلسطينيه وفصائل المقاومه هذا التصعيد
برسائل نتنياهو من خلال خطابه الاخير امام
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده واخيرا كيف
تنظر واشنطن للتطورات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وما ضماناتها لعدم تفجر
الاوضاع في المنطقه بسبب السياسات
الاحتلال وانسداد افق الحل السلمي
[موسيقى]
على اكثر من محور وصلت قوات الاحتلال
تصعيدها ضد الفلسطينيين الذي يتنوع في
الساعات الاخيره بين اقتحامات واغتيالات
واعتقالات واجتياح للمقدسات الفلسطينيه
ففي فجر الاحد قتلت قوات الاحتلال
فلسطينيين واصابت اخرين خلال اقتحامها
مخيمي نور شمس وطول كرم بالضفه الغربيه
كما دمرت ممتلكات عامه وخاصه اثناء
العمليه
هذه العمليه التي اقر فيها جيش الاحتلال
باصابه احد جنوده اثناء مواجهات مع مسلحين
فلسطينيين
وفي شمال رام الله اقتحمت قوه الاحتلال
جامعه بيرزيت واعتقلت ثمانيه طلاب والحقت
اضرارا بالممتلكات
وفي المسجد الاقصى الذي توالت اقتحامات
المتشددين عليه في الفتره الماضيه اقدم
اكثر من 500 متشددا يهودي ومستوطن على
اقتحامه صباح الاحد وذلك بحسب الاوقاف
الاسلاميه في القدس التي رجحت ازدياد عدد
المقتحمين بسبب استعداد اليهود لبدء
الاحتفال بما يسمونه يوم الغفران وقد
اعلنت السلطات الاحتلال تعزيز قوتها في
القدس وتحديدا في محيطي وداخل البلده
القديمه
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من بيت
لحم الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ومن نيوجيرسي
ريتشارد غوتس
الى مفاوضات السلام في الشرق الاوسط اهلا
بكما وابدا باك دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي اذا
اجتياح واعتقال اغتيال
وقصف واقتحام كله في يوم واحد
وفي كل الاراضي الفلسطينيه في القدس في
الضفه في غزه ما هي الرسائل او او بالاحرى
ما الذي يريده الاحتلال من هذا التصعيد
بهذا الشكل
الاحتلال يشن حرب دمويه على الشعب
الفلسطيني باسره وكما ذكرتم لم يترك موقعا
لم يهاجم فيها
هؤلاء الشهداء جعلوا عدد الشهداء منذ
بدايه هذا العام يتجاوز 242 شهيد ومنهم
بالمناسبه 39 طفل
اجتياحات واعتقالات لا تتوقف في كل مكان
ليس فقط مخيمات طولكرم مخيم جنين ونابلس
وعاقبه جبر في اريحا وكل المناطق
الفلسطينيه تتعرض لنفس الهجمات والان
اقدموا ايضا على اقتحام جامعه بيرزيد في
عمل مشين لم يحترموا حرمه الحرم الجامعي
وقاموا باغتقال الطلبه فيه ومنهم رئيس
مجلس الطلبه نفسه
هذا الذي يجري يرسل رساله واحده للشعب
الفلسطيني وهو ان الاحتلال يريد ان يقمع
ويكسر المقاومه الفلسطينيه
ويريد ان يهوض ويضم الضفه الغربيه بكاملها
وليس فقط الضفه الغربيه حتى قطاع غزه لا
يريد ان يبقي اثرا لوجود فلسطيني هنا
واكثر ما يلفت النظر واكثر الرسائل بلاغه
كانت ماء الخارطه التي حملها نتنياهو في
خطابه الوقح في الامم المتحده والتي اظهرت
وهي تضم جميع الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه
والجولان المحتل ايضا على مراه ومشهد من
العالم باسره على مراى ومشهد من الامم
المتحده التي يفترض ان تحمي القانون
الدولي على مراه ومشهد من الولايات
المتحده التي تواصل الحديث عن حل الدولتين
ولم نسمع ادانه او استنكارا لما يقوم به
نتنياهو ما فعل نتنياهو في الامم المتحده
ينفذ على الارض من خلال هذه الاجتياحات
المدمره ومع ذلك اسف ومع ذلك اخت ليلى
يفشل المره تلو الاخرى في وقف المقاومه
الفلسطينيه طيب على مراه العالم ايضا في
نيويورك التقاء بايدن ونتنياهو
هذا التصعيد كله ياتي بعد ايام فقط من هذا
اللقاء ماذا تقرا في التوقيت
اعتقد ان الخبر الابرز
لمصادر المياه والجثمين اللي موجوده في كل
مكان من هذه المنطقه هذا الاسبوع هو انه
يبدو ان هناك نوع من الاتفاق بين الولايات
المتحده والسعوديه واسرائيل والاراضي
الفلسطينيه انا هناك شيء ما يتم العمل
عليه بكل جديه يبدو انه اذا حصل ذلك سيكون
على اسرائيل ان تقدم تنازلات ضخمه جدا
من اجل شرعنه الدوله الفلسطينيه واعتقد ان
هذا هو الامر الابرز هذا الاسبوع الذي من
شانه ان يوقف سيد اسالك عن هذا التصعيد
الان انت تتحدث عن تنازلات هل هناك اي
مؤشر الى اي نوع من التنازلات على ضوء ما
نشهده اليوم
اعتقد انه يجب ان نفرق بين الجيش
الاسرائيلي
وما يرصد انه مرافق لصنع القنابل في مدن
في الضفه الغربيه
ومحاوله اذا ايقاف ذلك هذا ما تفعله حتى
الولايات المتحده لو وجدت ذلك على حدودها
هذا من جهه
ودخول اسرائيل الى المسجد الاقصى وهذا بكل
صراحه لا مبرره له وبالتالي انا افرق بين
هذين العملين وطبعا ما يحصل حين يدخل
الجيش الاسرائيلي في محاوله
لوقف مرافق ومواقع صنع القنابل يقف الناس
ليقاوموا وبالتالي يطلق الجيش الاسرائيليه
اذا الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي ما يقول ان
هذا ليس له علاقه بالتصعيد في الواقع هي
من حق اسرائيل ان تقوم بما تق وم به وليس
له علاقه بما قاله او اي لقاء او تنازلات
ما تعليقك
انا اسف ان اقول انا ضيفك يحاول ان يضللنا
بتجنب الحقائق الواضحه كالشمس
اولا ما يجري هو محاوله بيع وهم جديد
للفلسطينيين بعد ان باعوهم وهما اسمه
اتفاق اوسلو على مدار 30 عاما
والنتيجه ما حصدناه الاستيطان والضم
والتهويد ومليون عمليه اعتقال والاف
الشهداء ولم نحصل لا عدوله فلسطينيه ولا
على كيان فلسطيني الان يريد ترويج الاوهام
مره اخرى انه جرى تطبيع اوسع مع اسرائيل
قد يحصل الفلسطينيين على شيء والان لم يعد
الامر حتى حديث عن دوله بل عن تحسين احوال
المعيشه تحسين احوال الاضطهاد لا يمكن ان
يكون حلا لا يمكن تحسين احوال عبوديه شعب
تحت الاحتلال وتحت نظام العنصري النقطه
الثانيه
ليس من حق الشعب الذي تحت الاحتلال وتحت
نظام الافرتيد العنصري حسب ما ينص عليه
القانون الدولي ان يقاوم الاحتلال بكل
الوسائل وبكل الاشكال هذا ما ينص عليه
القانون الدولي يريد ان يجردوا الشعب
الفلسطيني من حقه في المقاومه حتى
المقاومه بالكلام يسمونه تحريضا حتى
المقاومه بالمقاومه الشعبيه يسمونها عنفا
والمقاومه المسلحه يسمونها ارهابا هذا
كلام مرفوض ومردود الذي يمارس الارهاب
قطعان المستوطنين الذين ينبغي اليوم 22
عضو في البرلمان الاسرائيلي يطالبون
بالافراج عن ذلك المستوطن الارهابي الذي
احرق عائله الدوابشه بكاملها ولم نسمع
انتقادا امريكيا على ذلك انا برايي هذا
انحياز مطلق لاسرائيل انحياز للروايه
الاسرائيليه محاوله مره اخرى لفرض التضليل
على الشعب الفلسطيني ولكن الشعب الفلسطيني
تعلم من تجربته ولن تنطلي علينا لعيب
اوسلو مره اخرى
قضيه ان من حق اي شعب تحت الاحتلال ان
يقاوم الاحتلال هذا منصوص عليه وفق
القانون الدولي وهذه نقطه يتم تجاهلها او
طمسها الى حد كبير في الاعلام الغربي ولكن
ما يجري في الاراضي المحتله الفلسطينيه
يندرج تحت هذا ويفترض ان اللقاء بين
نتنياهو
وبايدن كان تاخر بسبب تحفظات لدى بايدن من
تصرفات حكومه نتنياهو ولكن ما حصل بعد هذا
اللقاء
يعني هذا التصعيد الذي اعترضت عليه والذي
فهمت منه السلطه الفلسطينيه وفصائل اخرى
بانها الربط بينه وبين كلمه نتنياهو في
الامم المتحده الا يكرس التصعيد كمنهج
اعتقد ان المحامين والدبلوماسيين قد
يتناقشون ما اذا كانت المقاومه تشمل تفجير
القنابل في دول اخرى واعتقد انه مع بعض
الادله هذا ما يحصل هنا وربما هذا يدخل في
تعريف المقاومه انا لست هنا لكي احاجر حول
هذا الموضوع ولكن اقول ان بايدن كان واضحا
في انه مستعد لوضع الولايات المتحده في
الدفاع عن حق الدفاع عن النفس الذي يعود
لاسرائيل ويمكن ان نمضي اسابيع ربما
نناقش ما اذا كان وضع حد لمصانع او مرافق
صنع القنابل هو حق في المقاومه ولكن اباده
عائلات باكملها والطريقه اذا وضعنا يعني
لحظه فقط لاننا نرى على شاشات التلفزيون
مناظر فعلا يعني يندلها الجبين ايا كان
المصدر يعني
محتاجا ان تكون عربيا حتى تتعاطف مع هذه
المشاهد ولكن عندما ترى عائلات ونساء
وكبار السن يضربون بطريقه يعني بصراحه لا
اعرف كيف اصفها يعني
مؤلمه قليل بحقها كل هذا يفترض ان يقبل
هذا في اطار المسموح به
يعني متى متى سنصل الى مرحله يفهم فيها ان
هذا نوع من
رد الفعل على الطريقه التي يعامل فيها
الفلسطينيون
انا اوافقك الراي مئه في المئه
بان
وجود اسر لا علاقه لها بالعنف تتعرض للضرب
او حتى لضروب معامله اسوء من ذلك لا مبرر
لا منطق لا عذر لذلك
نقطه على السطر انا اوافقك الراي تماما
على ذلك
وقد شاهدنا على هذه الدوامه على مر عقود
وذلك منذ لقاء نتنياهو او ليس منذ لقاء
بعيدا فقط هذا تكرار حول هذا الموضوع
بالنسبه العلاقات وتطبيع العلاقات بين
اسرائيل والسعوديه اذا نحن كنتيجه لذلك لن
نتحدث عن تنازلات بالنسبه الى الفلسطينيين
ولكن السعوديه اصرت على تغيير جذري وماديا
وملموس في ظروف العيش في دفا الغربيه وغزه
قبل ان توافق على التطبيع واعتقد ان
الولايات المتحده ايضا تسير في نفس المسار
اذا سمحت لي اذا سمحت لي وصلتني الى نقطه
في الواقع يعني كانت قد اثارها بالامس فقط
في مقاله
وكان يشيد بحكمه
الرئيس بايدن وبانه خلف الحميميه التي ظهر
فيها معنى تنياهو والابتسامات كانت هناك
رساله قويه وجهها لنتنياهو من اجل تقديم
تنازلات حقيقيه
وتقليل هذا القمع للشعب الفلسطيني من
ضمننا هل واعود هنا لاسالك هل ما نراه
اليوم
يندرج في اطار
استعداد لتقديم تنازل
طبعا العنف الذي لا ضروره له لا يشكل اي
فكره عن التنازلات لا احد لديه هذه الفكره
عن تنازلات لا احد منا يعرف
الوقائع اذا كان هناك فعلا تصنيع للقنابل
واذا كانت سوف تستخدم في هذه المرافق او
المصانع التي تم الدخول اليها حتى لا يمكن
ان
يمسك اسرائيل عن تحرك لمنع هذا التهديد
ولانهائه ولكن بايدن اوصل بوضوح الى
نتانيا هو رساله مفادها ان الامور يجب ان
تتغير داخليا وفي الضفه الغربيه وغزه قبل
ان توافق الولايات المتحده على اي شيء
يبدو اكثر
دعما وبايضا كان ينتقد وبوضوح لي نتنياهو
ولم نشهد على اي رئيس من قبل سواء من
الحزب الديمقراطي او الجمهوري انتقد بهذه
الشده هو يعرف المنطقه هو يعرفون تانياهو
وهو يعرف ما هي خدعه نتانيا وهو حكيم في
هذا المجال وبالتالي اعتقد انه يجب
لا ننسى ذلك بالنظر الى فظاعه ما يحصل
هو ايضا قدم نفسه على انه اقوى صديق
للدوله لدوله اسرائيل وهذا يعني لا يقبل
مجال للشكوى اي تصرف حتى الان ربما يصب في
هذه النقطه واريد ان اسالك دكتور برغوثي
هل نستطيع نحن كعرب ان نفصل ربما هذه هذا
الانطباع وهذه النظره اللي هو قدمها بنفسه
خصوصا وان يعني الربط كانه دور الامريكي
الان في القضيه الفلسطينيه ينحصر في اطار
استعداد اسرائيل ومبادره اسرائيل للتطبيع
مع محيطها هل فعلا هنا ينحصر هذا الدور
الان في هذا الاطار
ينحسر الدور في خدمه مصالح اسرائيل هذا لا
شك فيه هذا ما نراه على ارض الواقع بايدن
اصلا قال عن نفسه انه صهيوني كبير
عندما جاء لزياره المنطقه وهو الان يقول
انه اكبر صديق واكبر داعم لاسرائيل هناك
سؤالان يعني بسيطان يجب ان يسال للجانب
الامريكي السؤال الاول الم يروا الخارطه
التي حملها نتنياهو في الامم المتحده الم
يروا ولم يسمعوا تصريحات نتنياهو انه لا
مكان لدوله فلسطينيه مستقله ولا يحق
للفلسطينيين ان يمتلك حق الفيتو على
التطبيع مع المحيط العربي الم يسمعوا ان
كل نظريته قائم على التطبيع مع الدول
العربيه من اجل تصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه
برمتها وتهميشها هل فعلت حكومه بايدن شيء
غير انها تريد ان تشجع التطبيع الذي بداوا
ترامب بالضغط على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في هذا الاتجاه ماذا فعلت
الفلسطينيين الولايات المتحده تقول انه هي
تؤيد حل وتقول ان الاستيطان يقتل حل
الدولتين وتقول ان اراد الفلسطينيه اراضي
محتله طيب اوكرانيا بيقولوا عنها ايضا
فيها اراضي محتله لماذا اوكرانيا مسموح
لها تستعمل قنابل ورصاص ودبابات وطائرات
وتمنعها الولايات المتحده مع الدول الاخرى
اكثر من 160 مليار دولار من الاسلحه اما
الشعب الفلسطيني بامكانياته البسيطه
والمتواضعه ممنوع مش بس يقاوم بالسلاح
ممنوع يتظاهر وممنوع يحتج وممنوع يعترض
باي حق لماذا هذه الازدواجيه الصارخه في
المعايير لا احد يستطيع ان يقنعنا بانه
هاي السياسه متوازنه هاي سياسه منحازه
بشكل مطلق لاسرائيل وهي التي تجعل شعوب
الارض وشعوب العالم مثل هذه السياسه
الحقيقه دامغه الحقيقه دامغه ورفعها
نتنياهو امام العالم كله انا اطالب الرئيس
الامريكي الان والاداره الامريكيه وكل
العالم الغربي ان يدين خارطه نتنياهو ان
كان حقا صادق وان لم يكن فليتركنا نناضل
من اجل حقوقنا لنتوقف فقط عند ردود الفعل
الفلسطينيه على التصعيد الاسرائيلي والذي
دانت فيه الرئاسه الفلسطينيه وحركه حماس
ذلك التصعيد واعتبرته تنفيذا لمخطط
نتنياهو الذي اعلن عنه والذي تمت الاشاره
اليه في الامم المتحده الناطق باسم
الرئاسه الفلسطينيين نبيل ابو ردينه حذر
من مغبه التصعيد الاسرائيلي وصفه بانه
خطير بحق الشعب الفلسطيني ومقدساته واضاف
ان الاحتلال يجر المنطقه لمربع العنف عبر
عدوانه المتواصل واقتحامه المسجد الاقصى
وجامعه بيرزيت اما اما حركه حماس فقد قالت
في بيان نعت فيه شهيدي طولكرم ان كل
محاولات وقت المقاومه ستتحطم وتفشل وسيخرج
المقاومون في كل وقت ومن كل مكان
برايك ما هو الدور الامريكي في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه خصوصا مع هذا التحذير من
الجانب الفلسطيني انه ممكن ان يشمل
المنطقه ككل
الواضح هو ان الولايات المتحده لا تريد
اطلاق صواريخ من حزب الله من حماس
ولا تريد ضروره الرد على هذه الصواريخ هذا
شيء الجميع لا يريده مره اخرى
الحكمه وراء هذا الاتفاق المحتمل الذي
تدخل فيه السعوديه هو حل الكثير من
المشاكل المتنوعه واعتقد انه يجب ان نتوقف
قبل ان نقوم بالمقارنه مع الوضع
نحن نتحدث عن موجه تصعيد حاليا
والدور الامريكي في
ايقافها
واحتوائها ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه الولايات
المتحده ما هي خياراتها الان
الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكن الولايات المتحده
ان تقوم به وان تنقل الى الطرفين رساله
مفادها ان هذا التصعيد الذي بدانا نراه لن
يكون مقبولا واعتقد ان نتانياهو
قد انجذب الى فكره الاتفاق مع السعوديه
لانه يدرك انه الولايات المتحده لا تعطيها
الكثير من هامش الحركه هو يدرك انه لم يعد
بامكانه ان يفعل ما هو يدرك ذلك واعتقد ان
الولايات المتحده
لنا دقيقه ونصف فقط اريد ان اسمع تعليق من
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي هل فعلا تفكير رغم
رغبوي من جانب واشنطن تعتقد انه يمكن فعلا
ان يستفيد الفلسطينيون من هذا النوع من
التطبيق
كيف يمكن ان يستفيد الفلسطينيون من تصفيه
قضيتهم وكيف يمكن ان نستفيد من اعطاء
اسرائيل مزيد من الوقت حتى تواصل ضم
وتهويد ما تبقى من الضفه الغربيه ما الذي
نستفيده في هذه الحاله لا شيء انا برايي
اذا كانت الولايات المتحده يعني يعني ضيفه
كان يجب ان يجيب اذا كانت الولايات
المتحده تريد ان تحدث تاثيرا فلتعلن انها
ستفرض عقوبات على اسرائيل فورا ان لم توقف
الاستيطان فقط لتوقف النشاط الاستيطاني
وتوقف اجتياحات المسجد الاقصى وتوقف
الاعتداءات على الاماكن الدينيه المقدسه
الاسلاميه والمسيحيه وتوقف عمليه تصفيه
وجود الشعب الفلسطيني عبر هذه الهجمات
البربريه لو قالت الولايات المتحده فقط
انها ستوقف مساعدات عن اسرائيل ما لم توقف
الاستيطان سند سنعتقد عندها ان هناك
هل ترى اي احتمال لمثل هذه المواقف
لا اعرف بشاني اي
عقوبات على اي تصرفات تعتبروا او يعتبر
الفلسطينيون انها غير مقبوله من قبل
اسرائيل ولكن اعتقد انا السبب الذي قربنا
اكثر من عمليه السلام من قبل
هو ان بايدن يعرف المنطقه واوصل الى
نتنياهو رساله
مبعوث الرئيس السابق قبل السلام في الشرق
الاوسط واشكر من بيت لحم الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه
واشكركم ايضا مشاهدينا على متابعه هذه
الحلقه
[موسيقى]